البدايه من تطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث
حذر وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
من ان روسيا تستعد للهجوم كبير جديد على
بلاده وكشف انه قد يبدا في اقرب وقت ممكن
بحلول الرابع والعشرين من فبراير الجاري
وقال ان موسكو حشدت الالاف من القوات
ويمكنها تجربه شيء ما بحلول الذكرى
السنويه الاولى للغزو وسيصادف الهجوم ايضا
يوم المدافع او المدافع عن ارض الاباء في
الثالث والعشرين من فبراير والذي يحتفي به
بالجيش الروسي كل عام واكد ريزنكوب ان
موسكو حشدت نحو 500 الف جندي لتنفيذ هذا
الهجوم
تصريحاته وزير الدفاع الاوكراني تتماهى مع
تحذير لمعهد دراسات الحرب الامريكي الذي
حذر من نيات روسيا اجراء عمليه هجوميه
حاسمه في دومباس متوقعا ان يحدث ذلك في
الشهر الحالي او الشهر المقبل المعهد ايضا
اشار مشاهدينا الى ان الحاله السيئه
للمعدات العسكريه الروسيه ستجبر القياده
العسكريه الروسيه على حشد المزيد من
القوات حتى تتفوق على عدد القوات
الاوكرانيه من اجل تحقيق المزيد من
المكاسب على ارض المعركه وسوف تركز جهودها
على تاكيد سيطرتها على كامل دونيسك وعلى
ايضا الرئيس الاوكراني بدوره فولدمير
اعترف في تقييم عسكري بان الوضع على خطوط
الاماميه في شرق البلاد يزداد صعوبه مع
تكثيف القوات الروسيه هجومها زيلينسكي
اشاره في خطابه للمسائي المصور الى ان
هناك زياده مؤكده في العمليات الهجوميه
للقوات الروسيه على الجبهه في شرق البلاد
مضيفا ان الروسي يحاولون مكاسب يمكنهم
التباهي بها في الذكرى الاولى للحرب في
الرابع والعشرين من فبراير ويزور اكثر من
عشره مسؤولين اوروبيين كبار العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كييف وذلك للقاء اعضاء في
الحكومه الاوكرانيه عشيه قمه بين الاتحاد
الاوروبي واوكرانيا ومن المقرر ان يلتقي
الرئيس الاوكراني مع رئيس المجلس الاوروبي
تشارل ميشيل وايضا رئيسه المفوضيه ارسل
غدا الجمعه وذلك للبحث في الدعم المالي
والدعم العسكري